forget him Paul Lowell has a beard up
you see for the prom his genitals to his
mouth
hey Kari Gareth yeah
thanks your cut on my house this is your
first time here I know well okay I told
you first of all my studio first of all
it's a lie that it's your place but it's
but it's also a live in the world of
lies that you've created that it's my
first time here we've done 30 of these
anyway thanks for coming by for your
first time and this is my house
obviously if it wasn't my house why with
my kid be here you know why would your
kid be well it's my house all right so
let's just roll this one I'm not even
gonna say I'm having to say what what
the cartoon is you'll see as soon as it
gets going I told you it's my place can
we just watch the cartoon I'm tired of
your game where you're like this isn't
your house it's just my kid that's all
just in our house all right
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all based on true and his when the
onion was just well god don't
the mothers still being sutured no she's
not citrus she split in half he was
already 25 feet tall sure fine wait it's
a good documentary I want a creep no
guts huh no no guts at all Wow Forrest
of the West
and found his job to chop down the trees
to make room
we're gonna make you so proud in the
future you're gonna love what we do to
the trees go get them Paul Owen has a
beard of you
put it from his genitals to his mouth :
save his balls and made of mustache
goatee hey Birds get out everybody run
who made that axe one swing what a
monster well this is before we do that
was the war axe was around couple miles
with every step
myoga once he started walking across the
country why he walked across Ohio
Indiana Illinois and then stepped into
the state of Wisconsin killing
hitchhikers the whole story's filled out
I can't get an erection
can you put me which ways west direction
[Music]
whoa ten miles what an one guy
thank you Paul Bunyan cried the farmer
you're welcome said Paul as he took an
extra big step and walked from Wisconsin
into Montana I've done yes Paul Bunyan
did some remarkable things all right so
far as a specific climate terrorist
oh the Hessian soldiers fired at him as
she picked up a tree trunk and bad at
their cat versus a tree literally not
posses balls that's not gonna happen
they never got once when boys yeah what
did Paul do through his feces at their
boat oh and I almost forgot he also
built the Rocky Mountain no absolutely
not no yeah I did it with his elder you
slid them over they had an AMOLED Oh
Liam it's moving on then allen wrench
it's like I can't
[Music]
Hey look what I did I'm crazy them came
though where's the new arm of his line
there we go
the country had no Inland Waterway learn
enough for big ships carrying heavy
Freight that's right we need 200 your
story doesn't age great no he wanted
rains SUNY Amazon rainforest needed to
go Alex ring-like we can use it we saw
the great links earlier when they went
over to this console without really a
vision in his head push Buffalo into the
water save us all a little trouble it's
God the river in his later years
with his big jobs done Paul Bunyan went
back to one of his favorite hobbies
mountain mate looks like he's making
mountains the old-fashioned way my stare
glory hole in the side of this mountain
don't you worry about that done balls
just had his way
oh no no Paul oh sorry
[Music]
where any attracted children so then it
just became away got younger did Paul
Bunyon really live no well nobody no no
no no we no destroyed he killed the
place where animals live everybody
he just punches his fist through the
ozone layer Paul budget time it
terrorism
well story uh story doesn't age great
story of Paul Bunyan does not eiffage
great none of that is true
well in a way it would make more sense
to have that than how we treat the
planet now in my opinion wow you're a
bummer
yeah yeah yeah
Paul Bunyan tree murderer tree mountain
inserter weirdo
what was that blue ox - that would have
been that would have made more sense
than anything else enough if he had a
blue ox thanks for swearing so much
wrong my kid
[Music]